[Applause]
and finally new rule of Halloween is too
much for your fragile sensibilities and
you're worried about seeing someone
wearing something that's on the
Forbidden costume list
[Applause]
just stay the [ __ ] home
every year we go through this [ __ ]
lists of costumes you better not wear
unless the night of irreverent dress-up
spiral into something that resembles fun
[Laughter]
here's an idea click bait websites I
won't tell you how to harvest and sell
my personal data
and you don't tell me what I can wear on
Halloween
because
Halloween is supposed to be outrageous
it's a festival of the sacrilegious and
a celebration of the grotesque from
zombies to ghouls to bobbing for apples
and other people's saliva
yet every year there's a new list of
offensive things we shouldn't do on the
day that's all about being offensive
you know what I want to cancel November
1st all scolds day
when the good people announce which
costumes the bad people wore BuzzFeed I
mean buzz kill
has a list of 23 costumes they're
literally begging you not to wear of
course this year the number one No-No is
serial killer Cannibal and Netflix
sensation Jeffrey Dahmer
eBay has already banned selling it
because otherwise it would be impossible
to find a blonde wig in aviator glasses
on biles tweeted put the Jeffrey Dahmer
costumes back in the closet we ain't
having it
who's we
what's with the Wii who died and made
you the Great Pumpkin
I'm so tired of a handful of emotional
hemophiliacs
on social media telling us what we can't
do on Halloween and by the way please
put drugs in my candy
listen to these other verboten costumes
on stupid lists this year including
Queen Elizabeth because it's too soon
yes 96 practically in ingenue
foreign
of course don't even think about
characters outside of your race and no
no Genies because Genies were slaves
okay no sexy school girls no Playboy
bunnies no celebrities accused of
pedophilia including Elvis you can't
dress up as Elvis that's an entire
industry
[Applause]
no zombie versions of deceased
celebrities well there goes my zombie
Angela Lansbury idea
foreign
no unhoused person what we used to call
a hobo the default costume of every kid
in history
no one with an eating disorder so
goodbye skeletons
and no transphobic costumes because if
kids want to see drag queens they can go
to Story Hour
also listen to this no Putin
no Trump
know anything related to the Will Smith
Oscar slap
no Johnny Depp and of course Amber Heard
is out no [ __ ]
and nothing related to vaccines or covet
or monkey pox
so have fun kids and let your
imagination soar
can I tell you something kids these are
all great costumes foreign
listen to me I'm your last connection to
fun
you should wear all of them in fact
combine them if you want have the queen
[ __ ] in Johnny's bed
[Applause]
have Will Smith smacking a hobo
Kevin Spacey hitting on a mariachi band
Jeffrey Dahmer is the perfect Halloween
costume what is scarier than a guy who
[ __ ] you kills you and eats you not
necessarily in that order
for [ __ ] sake it's Halloween which is
not just a fun holiday it's a necessary
psychic release yes Society is going
back thousands of years knew that you
had to have some release valve on the
calendar to flirt with the Macabre and
let the demons out to role plays or they
wouldn't come out later for real Mexico
has Day of the Dead Japan has Oban
Haitians have fed g'day it's not a
coincidence that carnival comes right
before lent and Halloween right before
All Saints Day much the way getting
blown at a bachelor party comes before
the wedding
foreign
you know I find it so interesting you
would think that a handmaid's tale
costume would be acceptable since it
derives from a completely woke approved
show that condemns the patriarchy no
buzzkill says no handmaid's tail costume
either because it hits a little too
close to home right now
okay this is the life philosophy of
zelenials things that are interesting
might also contain something which could
cause a moment of discomfort so ban it
all
it's not your fault kids your parents
ruined You by over protecting you and
now you're these [ __ ]
and that is the craziest part of all
this being irreverent unclenched
and playful should be the province of
the young but it's not boomers are
supposed to be to get off my lawn crowd
but when someone in a problematic
costume shows up at your door it's
literally gen Z telling them to get off
my lawn
except it's not even your lawn because
you live at your parents house
so
what better Doom to wear this year then
the most ridiculous one I could think of
you
this year I'm going as an Uber woke
overly anxious perpetually offended 20
something would you like to see what I
have for this costume I think you're
going to really enjoy it
okay first of all I have my [ __ ] the
patriarchy t-shirt
oh yes and then I have a check from the
patriarchy to pay my car insurance
[Applause]
okay I've got my uh my nose ring
my I know my vape pen
I've got my cloth surgical mask
my surgical mask my n95 mask and my face
shield
[Applause]
then after I leave the house
I have my Klonopin to take the edge off
my Adderall to put it back on
I have my participation trophy
my cat ear headphones to listen to sad
music the stick that goes up my ass
and the least for my support enemy
and just in case anyone still doesn't
get what I'm all about I have a wet
blanket
[Applause]